[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
ihnen allen einen schönen guten abend
alles was wichtig ist und wird in den
nächsten 20 minuten und sportlich ist
wird natürlich dazu heute wieder mit
kristin otto man es gibt einiges guten
abend hier sind unsere themen
tödlicher tornados in den usa in
kentucky und anderen bundesstaaten
sterben mehr als 70 menschen die
behörden befürchten viele weitere opfer
spd wählt neue parteispitze lars
klingbeil wird neuer co vorsitzender ex
juso chef kevin kühnert neuer
generalsekretär
warnung an russland in liverpool beraten
die g7 außenminister unter anderem über
den ukraine konflikt
bevor wir über die neue spd parteispitze
berichten konzentrieren wir unseren
blick auf das was us-präsident beiden
eine unvorstellbare tragödie nennt nach
dutzenden tornados beklagt man in sechs
us-bundesstaaten zahlreiche todesopfer
und verheerende verwüstungen
am schwersten hat es den bundesstaat
kentucky getroffen aber auch in
tennessee mississippi arkansas missouri
und illinois wüteten die unwetter nina
niebergall berichtet
vom historischen zentrum in mayfield
kentucky ist nur ein riesiges
trümmerfeld übrig die kleinstadt im
herzen der usa komplett zerstört viele
menschen werden noch vermisst
ich mir meine frau finden ich hoffe sie
ist in sicherheit wird der ruf mich an
sobald du kannst
seine frau arbeitete dieser kerzenfabrik
wegen weihnachten lief der betrieb rund
um die uhr sie war unter den 110
menschen im gebäude als die tornados in
der nacht kentucky trafen
leider sind viele häuser völlig
verwüstet in den sich vermutlich
menschen befanden das werden die
tödlichsten tornados sein die jemals
kentucky getroffen haben
auch andere bundesstaaten sind betroffen
in eli neue stürzte das dach eines
amazon verteilzentrums ein mindestens
zwei menschen sind tot einige wurden in
der nacht noch vermisst
habe gegen 20 uhr heute abend mit meinem
mann gesprochen da ist er zurück zum
lagerhaus um seinen lieferwagen
abzugeben ich habe seitdem nichts mehr
von ihm gehört
mehr als 30 tornados verwüsteten teile
des landes wie groß das ausmaß dieser
zerstörung ist wird sich vermutlich erst
in ein paar tagen zeigen fest steht die
zahl der toten könnte noch steigen
jetzt zur spd seit dem wahlsieg und der
kanzlerschaft herrschen in der sonst so
streitlustigen partei ja wieder harmonie
und selbstbewusstsein und das wurde auch
bei der heutigen wahl zur neuen
parteiführung deutlich aus der
doppelspitze mit saskia esken hatte sich
ja norbert walter borjans zurückgezogen
sein nachfolger heißt seit heute lars
klingbeil dessen posten als
generalsekretär ging an den früheren
juso chef kevin kühnert lars bruhns und
andreas huppert haben den wechsel
beobachtet die spd-spitze sortiert sich
neu lars klingbeil wird co vorsitzende
an der seite von saskia esken sein
ergebnis 86,3 prozent ein
vertrauensvorschuss für den mann der den
wahlkampf der spd erfolgreich gemanagt
und er noch einiges erreichen will liebe
genossinnen und genossen wir sind eine
stolze partei die wahnsinnig viel
erreicht hat aber ich sage euch auch wir
noch wahnsinnig viel vor ich bin fest
davon überzeugt wir stehen an der
schwelle zu einem sozialdemokratischen
jahrzehnt nicht aus selbstzweck sondern
weil wir eine idee davon haben was gut
ist für die menschen und unser land in
den nächsten jahren die parteispitze
deutlich verjüngt als generalsekretär
folgt der ehemalige juso chef kevin
kühnert der einstige scholz gegner reiht
sich ein attacken auf den spd kanzler
sind von ihm wohl nicht mehr zu erwarten
möchte alles dafür geben der
sozialdemokratischen partei ihrer sache
ihren beschlüssen und ihren aktuell so
stolzen mitgliedern in den kommenden
zwei jahren als generalsekretär dienen
zu dürfen olaf scholz mahnt die spd nur
das zu versprechen was sich auch in der
regierungspolitik umsetzen lässt die
bürgern bürger müssen das gefühl
entwickeln und das vertrauen das was
öffentlich gesagt wird hinterher auch
umgesetzt wird in der politik die
geschlossenheit der letzten monate setzt
sich auf diesem weitgehend digitalen
parteitag fort dennoch das eigentliche
machtzentrum dürfte künftig eher das
kanzleramt sein als die parteizentrale
der spd
schauen wir jetzt auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen das robert koch institut
meldet 53
1697 neuinfektionen an einem tag zehn
1813 weniger als vor einer woche
510 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
cupid 19 die inzidenz sinkt auf firma
2,9 mittlerweile haben 22 5 prozent der
bevölkerung die so genannte booster
impfung erhalten
zunehmend sorgen macht die omikron
variante vor allem weil sie sich rasant
ausbreitet intensivmediziner warnen
heute schon im januar wird sie bei uns
vorherrschend sein laut robert koch
institut wurde omikron bis ende
vergangener woche in mehr als 50 ländern
nachgewiesen 18 davon liegen in europa
in deutschland gegen das rk ii bis zu
dem zeitpunkt von 64 fällen aus schwere
verläufe waren nicht dabei pablo sie la
la he
noch sind die zahlen hierzulande
überschaubar aber das ist das tückische
an der omicron variante sie verbreitet
sich besonders rasant jeden südafrika
und großbritannien etwa verdoppelt sich
die zahl der infektionen alle drei bis
vier tage
anfang des jahres dominant wird in
deutschland das heißt sie sind gut
beraten jetzt schon maßnahmen zu
überlegen gemeinsam mit der politik um
gewappnet zu sein falls durch amerika
mehr patienten auf unsere
intensivstation kommen sollten von der
neuen variante könnten auch vermehrt
kinder betroffen sein grund zur panik
gebe es aber nicht oregon soll bei
kindern mehrere schwere verläufe machen
den südafrika ob das in deutschland auch
so sein wird das wissen wir noch nicht
aber auch hier geld weiter klug und
vorsichtig handeln auch auf micro bei
erwachsenen häufiger zu schweren
krankheitsverläufen führt könne man
jetzt noch nicht absehen erfahrungen aus
großbritannien aber weisen auf einen
milden verlauf hin auch für das impfen
bedeutet omikron eine neue
herausforderung eine doppelte impfung
bietet laut studien keinen ausreichenden
schutz der hausärzteverband rechnet
damit dass bereits im kommenden herbst
eine vierte impfung notwendig wird wir
wissen nicht genau wie lange der
impfschutz anhält wissen nicht was an
weiteren möglichen varianten dieses
virus auf uns zukommt so dass ich damit
rechnen würde dass man wahrscheinlich
nochmal impfungen benötigt im verstelle
wie bei jan tag arbeiten zudem an einem
neuen impfstoff der an die omikron
variante angepasst ist liefer fertig
wird der aber wohl frühestens im märz
nächsten jahres sein
im kampf gegen korona lässt sich die
bundesregierung künftig von einem neuen
expertenteam beraten laut welt am
sonntag gehören dem gremium unter
anderem die beiden virologen christian
drosten und hendrik strikt an beide
experten hatten sich zuletzt teilweise
sehr unterschiedlich zu nötigen corona
maßnahmen geäußert
einigen menschen gehen die pläne der
regierung nach wie vor zu weit in
mehreren deutschen städten protestierten
sie auch heute wieder gegen die aktuelle
pandemie politik allein in hamburg waren
nach angaben der polizei rund 8000
demonstranten unterwegs die kundgebung
in der innenstadt verlief friedlich
protestmärsche gab es auch in schwerin
trier und frankfurt am main
wird deutschlands neue außenministerin
berbalk wirklich wie angekündigt mehr
klartext sprechen beim aktuellen
g7-gipfel dem treffen der führenden
westlichen industriestaaten in liverpool
hätte sie dazu die gelegenheit
vor allem über den umgang mit china in
menschenrechtsfragen oder russland in
der ukraine krise wollen sich die g7
abstimmen andreas künast ist nah dran
und zeigt uns was bislang dabei
herausgekommen ist
in den kleinen schwarzen kasten kommen
die handys keine ausnahme auch für den
us außenminister nicht die g7 wollen
offen reden über russland china myanmar
den iran dass die neue am tisch schon im
wahlkampf angekündigt hat sich klarer
und kritischer gegenüber
menschenrechtsverletzungen zu äußern
kommt den gastgebern entgegen
wir brauchen einen positiven ansatz um
unsere sicherheit und
wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu stärken und die
werte an die wir glauben
in liverpool steht die weltbühne an dem
wochenende an dem berbalk sie betritt
jetzt gilt es die usa drängen
deutschland zum diplomatischen boykott
der olympischen spiele in china italien
ist er dagegen großbritannien drängt
bernburg nord stream 2 zu verhindern
japan drängt zu mehr härte gegen china
berbalk muss in diesen fragen einseitige
festlegungen vermeiden aber auch die
akzente setzen die die ampel koalition
versprochen hat das betrifft den
klimaschutz betrifft eben genauso
geostrategische fragen wo rein
investieren wir eigentlich in welche
regionen und wie können wir da liberale
demokratien stärken einigkeit der g7
gibt berbalk in russland ukraine
konflikt bekannt es dürfe zu keiner
grenzverschiebung kommen in drei wochen
geht die britische t 7 präsidentschaft
zu ende im nächsten jahr heißt der
gastgeber deutschland und die
gastgeberin der burg
fragen sie doch mal nach bei diana
zimmermann die in liverpool beim gipfel
dabei ist erster auftritt auf großer
internationaler bühne welchen eindruck
hinterlässt deutschlands neue
außenministerin
das ist natürlich wirklich ein harter
einstieg hier auf einen schlag alle
kollegen der g7 kennen zu lernen und
dann auch noch mit ihnen gemeinsam zu
versuchen antworten auf krisen zu finden
wie die welt sie schon lange so nicht
gesehen hat iran china die spannungen
mit russland und natürlich die pandemie
und die klimakrise annalena baerbock hat
mit ihrem ersten statement bis vor
eineinhalb stunden gewartet einziges
vordruck wirkte sie sehr konzentriert
und vorsichtig nicht als hätte sie das
schon hundertmal gemacht aber das hat
sie natürlich auch nicht sehr
entschieden war sie als es um ihre ziele
ging für die g7 präsidentschaft
deutschlands die nächstes jahr beginnt
sie hat immer wieder betont wie viel
wert darauf legt dass multilateral
zusammengearbeitet wird dass man
gemeinsam vorausschauend auf krisen und
konflikte eingeht das sendet natürlich
auch die botschaft dass sie in ihrer
rolle als ministerin angekommen ist dass
sie weiß sie muss sich abstimmen mit
internationalen partnern und dem kanzler
alleingänge sind da erst mal nicht zu
erwarten schön dank nach liverpool diana
zimmermann
für unicef ist die korona pandemie die
größte krise seit gründung des un
kinderhilfswerkes und das war vor 75
jahren corona hat weltweit millionen in
die armut gestürzt die zahl der armen
kinder ist in zwei jahren um 100
millionen auf 1,1 milliarden gestiegen
weil ihre eltern wegen corona die arbeit
verlieren leiden auch in nigeria viele
mädchen und jungen unter hunger und von
dort berichtet jetzt susan vorne
lojewski
zusammen zu trainieren sport zu machen
in der gruppe das war für diese
jugendlichen in lagos bis vor kurzem
nicht möglich der charakter und hatte in
diese freiheit genommen vor allem aber
hatte das hilfsprojekt von unicef
geschlossen in der die jungen auch mit
essen versorgt werden
viele waren nicht in der lage sich zu
ernähren sondern hungrig und uns war
klar dass die meisten von ihnen in
unserer einrichtung kommen um mindestens
zweimal am tag etwas zu essen 2 kommen
die 100 millionen kinder weltweit so
unicef sind während der pandemie in
armut abgerutscht über 1,6 milliarden
konnten zumindest zeitweise nicht zur
schule gehen so wie auch james joseph wo
sein vater ist weiß er nicht auch die
mutter kann ihm nicht helfen
mein papa und meine mama sind nicht mehr
zusammen meine tante hat sich um mich
gekümmert aber sie konnte meine
ausbildung nicht mehr bezahlen und jetzt
liebe ich auf der straße
vermehrt erleben kinder besonders in
afrika in corona zeiten auch häusliche
gewalt der 16 jährige akin hatte es bei
der familie seiner schwester nicht mehr
ausgehalten
aber immer genervt er kam einfach zu mir
hat mir eine runter gehauen oder mich
geschlagen gründen in dem unicef
hilfsprojekt werden die jugendlichen
jetzt eine ausbildung machen bekommen
regelmäßiges essen können sich waschen
es ist ein kleiner lichtblick in zeiten
der pandemie
was macht ein astronaut auf der iss was
nutzen die experimente die dort gemacht
werden und wie wird im weltraum
eigentlich aufgeräumt all das fragen die
kinder heute stellen konnten und
matthias maurer der seit november auf
der iss ist hat sie beantwortet hinter
der aktion stehen der bundespräsident
und die stiftung kinderherz die sich für
kinder mit herzfehler einsetzt susanne
freitag mit mehr
was er sich da um schnallt ist ein orbit
tauglicher staubsauger jeden samstag
steht bei matthias maurer putzen der iss
auf dem plan aber das ist heute nicht
das einzige unten auf der erde rück
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
ein gesteck korrekt ins bild er wird
gemeinsam mit kindern in münchen und im
saarland fragen an den astronauten
stellen wie wird da oben geforscht wie
war die ankunft wie ist es wenn man die
welt zum ersten mal von oben sieht wenn
ich an diesem moment zurückdenke dann
habe ich jetzt noch gänsehaut über den
ganzen körper das ist ein bild was ich
nur sehr sehr schwer beschreiben kann
weil es einfach so so so emotional ist
dass mir die worte fehlen und jedes
video jedes futter was ich bisher
gesehen habe beschreibt die sache
eigentlich nur mit fünf prozent jetzt
gehen wir in die alle diese kinder haben
seit der geburt einen herzfehler
matthias maurer ist botschafter der
stiftung kinderherz erforscht im all
nach lösungen wir hatten hier sogar
schon schlagende herzmuskelzellen das
ist jetzt alles noch grundlagenforschung
aber wenn man diese forschung weiter
betreibt dann kann es möglich sein dass
dieser herzmuskeln vielleicht in zukunft
auch dazu dienen herzkranken kindern es
ermöglichen eine zweite eine normale
herzkammer dazu operiert zu bekommen
aber der astronaut ist ihr
hoffnungsträger
geregt dass sich der mann sich den
erzählerischen haben sondern auch noch
weitere gehen können
bis ende april wird maurer weiter
forschen in über 400 kilometer höhe
zurück zur erde und zum formel 1 sonntag
das letzte wm rennen und es geht um den
titel kämpfen will ein krimi in der
wüste großer showdown in abu dhabi max
verstappen hat zunächst die nase vorn
bestzeit im qualifying vor
titelverteidiger lewis hamilton ein
fantastisches gefühl genau das was wir
wollen so der niederländer der seinem
ersten wm titel anpeilt in der hitze der
nacht in abu dhabi behält max voß tappen
die nerven und stellt seinen red bull
auf startposition eins poleposition die
beste ausgangsposition für das letzte
saisonrennen weltmeister lewis hamilton
versucht alles um den niederländer noch
die bestzeit zu entreißen verpasst sie
aber um fast vier zehntel überraschender
dritter länder norris im mclaren
sebastian vettel hier links unten im
stau auf dem yas marina circuit
startplatz 15 mit schumacher rang 19
vorteil oder an ihr vorteil max voß
tappen für das spannendste finale seit
jahren
der rekordmeister zu hause in rückstand
am ende aber doch der gewinner des 5
zehnten spieltages der fußball
bundesliga
die bayern drehen die partie gegen mainz
musealer erzielt das 2 1 in bochum
sichert julian brandt verfolger dortmund
kurz vor abpfiff das 1 1 freiburg
unterliegt hoffenheim 1 2 beim
erfolgreichen debüt von trainer der sco
mit leipzig kassiert gladbach mit 1 4
die nächste klatsche hertha-sieg
bielefeld zwei zu null das abendspiel
wolfsburg/stuttgart ausführlich im
sportstudio gestern kölns erste heim
niederlage 0 2 gegen augsburg in der
tabelle erbaute bayern münchen seinen
vorsprung auf den bvb auf sechs punkte
aus hoffenheim nun einen punkt vor
freiburg leipzig klettert hoch auf 7
punktgleich vor mainz köln runter auf 11
gladbach nach drei niederlagen auf 13
stuttgart kann sich noch vor augsburg
schieben bielefeld und führt unverändert
die schlusslichter und mehr vom 23 uhr
an im aktuellen sportstudio und dem max
eberl gladbachs sportdirektor zur krise
der fohlen gilt es einiges zu sagen hat
zum wintersport rekord weltmeister
francesco friedrich bleibt im bob
weltcup weiter ungeschlagen mit einem
großartigen zweiten lauf verbesserte er
sich mit seiner 4eco vom dritten auf den
ersten platz sein siebter triumph im
siebten rennen dieses olympia-winters
teamkollege johannes lochner blieb mal
wieder rang zwei
keinen podestplatz für die deutschen
skispringer aber zwei vierte plätze da
punktgleich für markus eisenbichler und
karl geiger in klingenthal überraschend
sechster andreas wellinger beim sieg des
österreichers stefan kraft bei den
frauen ebenfalls von der großschanze
springt katharina althaus auf rang drei
die vierte podestplatzierung im sechsten
springen für die in diesem winter wieder
beste deutsche skispringerin überragende
athletin auch in klingenthal ist marita
kramer saisonsieg nummer vier mit großem
vorsprung die österreicherin führt auch
im gesamtweltcup vor katharina althaus
ja viel los so weit unserer highlights
dann vielen dank christin und von uns
weiß dass das wetter gibt's gleich mit
osten terli und um 22.45 marietta slomka
zum heute journal dann sage ich noch mal
einen schönen dritten advent aber vorher
noch einen schönen samstagabend für sie
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter fällt es zu heute
kommt deutlich mildere luft aus dem
westen zu uns aber auch regen ist mit im
gepäck und während das weiter nach osten
zieht wird es vor allem in den
mittelgebirgen teils für glatte straßen
sorgen in der nacht gibt es nach
nordosten hin einige schneeschauer das
zieht ab auch im süden am alpenrand es
wird weniger der zweiten nachthälfte
kommt von westen regen auf wobei sie
müssen im süden und im osten verbreitet
mit überfrierender nässe rechnen
temperaturen dazu -5 gerade im osten
deutschlands und 3 grad am niederrhein
und schon morgen im tagesverlauf
verlagern sich die wolken weiter
richtung mitte dabei kann der erste
regen er fällt in den mittelgebirgen
durchaus so glatte straßen sorgen ein
paar schneeflocken sind auch dabei ganz
im süden sprinzl mal die sonne hervor
und da es bei maximal temperaturen von
null grad im vogtland und elf grad ganz
im westen deutschlands die kommenden
tage am montag im süden etwas regen
sonst überwiegend trocken bei drei bis
elf grad dienstag nach osten hin etwas
regen sonst aber trocken zwei bis neun
grad und mittwoch im norden regen 2 bis
10 grad ein schöner ab